the Joe Rogan experience almost like
what Mighty Mouse did he was like okay
with leaving because he was a UFC champ
super dominant he didn't really lose
that say you to fight in my eyes I don't
think he lost that fight I think it
worse at best it was a draw I know I
don't think there was any real clear-cut
loser but I didn't think say you don't
won
I didn't think Mighty Mouse lost but for
him to go to another organization and if
he does win the belt
it's like arguably like you really can't
deny the guy is one of the goats if not
Viggo you know so that's the way I kind
of look at it and I probably be retired
anyway cuz 32 is close now you can't
deny him anyway
I mean no matter what happens from here
on out my mouse in my opinion
technically is the best ever
best ever technically the thing about
him versus John Jones in my eyes that
John is face stiffer competition yeah
I think John just fought more dangerous
guys and also John is completely
undefeated you know has that one loss -
Matt Hamill which is a disqualification
in a fight where he was totally dominant
in where I think was a bad call anyway
yeah I thought Matt was [ __ ] them up
but then I look at it like this see now
that Mighty Mouse is removed and there's
new life at the flyweight division
everything is super competitive now
right so it goes to show maybe it speaks
volume on just how good Mighty Mouse
just really is compared to everybody
else maybe that's why the division just
looked like that people like oh you're
just little guys not like fighting the
big guys I get that but it's like the
same thing with John Jones but now
there's like close to competition now
you see John John's going to decisions a
lot more as opposed to finishing the
older veterans who the pioneers who were
the the Shogun who was the rampage
Jackson's the who else says he murdered
Vlad that mata'utia I mean he wasn't no
champ but um Vitor Belfort like those
guys even though Vitor almost snapped
that arm in half was crazy [ __ ]
insane I jumped out of my [ __ ] well
that showed you what an animal John is
yeah didn't tap he just let his arm get
[ __ ] jacked and then wanna tap at
Vitor the next round
yeah John is he's not just talented his
mind is just unstoppable it's got
incredible his ability to overcome
adversities ability to get out of bad
situation its ability to press on we saw
that in the Gustafson fight me he wasn't
in shape for that fight at all yeah they
said he was barely training bra ice I've
party with John not like the hardcore
party that he does that he has done let
me say he has done I'm not sure party
I'm not sure if he still parties like
that but when he was partying I would
see him at the bar in Ithaca or he'll
come out to Courtland college cuz ethica
was right down the road this is like
when he was kind of going back and forth
between Jackson's and our gym when I was
upstate at bomb squad right before he
like officially left and then he was
just coming home and going back to
Jackson's coming home going back to
Jackson's and it would be like a couple
of weeks before his fighting this guy
would be out there shots and he'll be
like asking me if I want a drink in like
hell dude I'm fighting like for like
four weeks I can't I can't do that I
have to have a hard time cutting weight
for him I was like dude you don't like
you know it's not hard for you to cut
waves you get [ __ ] up like this I
think I didn't ask him that but I was
like I totally I got a fight coming up
I'm like but I know you got a fight
coming up that clearly does not [ __ ]
matter because you're John Jones you
just going out there to people anyway I
find was it what he said of Daniel
Cormier I've beat you when I was on
cocaine yeah yeah
cocaine's a hell of a job so the crazy
thing to say to someone I beat you and I
did cocaine yeah that says laughing that
says a lot don't man it doesn't DC's a
[ __ ] animal you know so I was like
it's just John Jones DC and then
everybody else you know he's that good
man but I'll tell you what man that
Thiago Santos is a [ __ ] yeah he
kicked the [ __ ] out of John's legs put
him in real danger and you know I think
John would have made a way easier fight
if he decided to take him to the ground
but he never did
yeah see and I talked about that fight
on my podcast this morning I do don't
want to tell you what your podcast is
where they get it oh the weekly scraps
you could get it on itunes spotify
google play tune in and my website i'll
just on that come i'll back young'n so
what you say but I was see the way I
broke that fight down I was like John
was always the guy the aggressor pushing
forward walking him down cutting him
against cut him
him off and pushing him back towards a
cage and then Thiago looked like he was
just kind of waiting and waiting to
pounce like he was looking for John to
take a half step where he could time it
while he was off balance and try to rush
him and blitzen with those big bungalows
he was doing as a rampage Jackson calls
him so I didn't feel like he connected
on anything significant besides the leg
kick early in the first round where it
kicked is like I was alright this fight
is gonna be interesting because he's
attacking the legs early but then he who
started attacking the legs more but I
felt like some of it wasn't really like
it didn't seem like it was really
affecting John the way people like
watching it live I thought it was
landing a lot more and then when I
rewatched it I was like I don't know I
have to really like I'm looking at it I
put it in slow-mo and I'm watching the
fighting like well that punch didn't
connect that punch did connect then he
did the one head kick that John got his
Hannibal at the very last second it was
able to block it the one Dana White
posted like a picture on Instagram was
saying how tough he was fighting on the
torn ACL the PCL and like the MCL and
MCL and meniscus his [ __ ] knee is
gone yeah I don't what was that the
first or second right was that service
round first round might have been a sec
but yeah that's a kick and we noticed
his knee buckle yeah okay and um I was
the first round was the first so I
wasn't fractured shin yeah
fracture shaken I thought oh that was
one team two would have buckled and he
threw a throwing that motherfucker's
crazy like that's hardcore
yeah that's the big one that's the big
shin bone not the smaller one the fibula
yeah the cc's of blood right god they're
pulling out a quart of milk out of his
[ __ ] me woohoo look at and they've
already got a bunch in that little
bucket yeah dr. Sanders did that right
holy [ __ ] man in the UFC yeah things we
did that operation ah oh my god yeah
that knee is mangled so he had a
immediately go into surgery after that
yeah
his knee was mangled and bastard well I
tough guy yeah I just felt like John was
still controlling dictating like the
control like the wounds and like like it
looked like those moments was like oh
but he didn't really hit him well he
definitely kicked the [ __ ] out of his
had to be carried out in the wheelchair
landed some shots to the head with
punches but John moved with them yeah
rolling yeah he rolled with them he kept
his hands up he got caught but he moved
back he's amazing and he's the best ever
at controlling distance he does the
finger at the finger range the pokey
rage but your left foot I'm like dude no
one's gonna get past those long as
[ __ ] go-go-gadget inspector arms you
know yeah but it's dangerous when the
eyes get in them yes because they have
happened it happened to a bottle he's
claimed you know how they have Ronda
Rousey collecting arms on the show like
they did those pitches John's got like
eyeballs no it's a whole light
heavyweight division is in a strange
state right now because it's like he got
John Jones and then who else you know
you got Johnny Walker who was looked
fantastic when he knocked out meter cone
off but then he fell down and [ __ ]
yourself up his shoulders still [ __ ]
up man just they showed him doing rehab
like real recently on his Instagram page
and I'm like whoa this was like six
months later if that's all he can lift
like that's like stabilizer muscles and
stuff that's around the shoulder that
shoulder might be [ __ ]
[Applause]